[Musik]
der ehemalige kgb-agent sergej chernoff
heute lebt er in frankreich in den 1980
er jahren studiert er an einer kgb elite
hochschule in moskau zu derselben zeit
wie ein anderer kgb offizier wladimir
putin
auf dieser schule lernt man eine ganze
reihe von spionage techniken und rot
unter anderem studiert man aber auch
psychologie und wie man menschen
manipulieren kann man lernt wie man
liebt und das muss zu ihrer zweiten
natur werden denn wenn sie ins ausland
gehen arbeiten sie eher verdeckt oder
mit einer legende
1980 ist sagte chernoff in moskau hier
finden gerade die olympischen spiele
statt der junge russe ist ausgebildet
für den einsatz in frankreich und er
telefoniert viel mit dem westen einmal
offenbar zu lange im kgb wird man
misstrauisch man bringt ihn zum verhör
in die gefürchtete kgb zentrale lubjanka
und
der mann der mich befragte war hauptmann
wladimir putin
er ist sehr kalt er ist sehr berechnet
aber er ist ein mensch der leicht
reizbar denn eigentlich spielt er die
kälte nur um seine wahre natur zu
verbergen die ziemlich gewalttätig ist
putin kann seinen kollegen chernoff
nichts nachweisen seine gewalttätiger
natur wird ihm aber noch schaden putin
ist in moskau in eine schlägerei
verwickelt
die polizei ermittelt dennoch ist
überzeugt dass vladimir putin auch
deshalb nie als agent im westen zum
einsatz kam sondern in die ddr nach
dresden geschickt wurde
am ende seines studiums stellte die
spionage schule fest diese person ist
gefährlich dieser mann ist ein risiko
weil er entscheidungen aus dem moment
heraus treffen kann aus einem gefühl der
kann cholerisch sein und gewalttätig
werde
der fall der mauer 1989 wird für putin
zu einem trauma als in dresden menschen
auf die straße gehen und drohen den kgb
sitz zu stürmen er bittet putin die
unterstützung sowjetischer soldaten
[Musik]
aus der sowjetischen militär basis hieß
es man könne nichts tun weil in moskau
niemand antwortet sie sagten moskau
schweigt
es war als ob moskau alle vorposten
seines imperiums aufgab und alles woran
er glaubte um ihn herum zerfiel
putin ist überzeugt der westen will
russland sprechen sein misstrauen und
seine angst vor verschwörungen sind tief
verwurzelt in der zeit des kalten
krieges und des kgb es hat den späteren
präsidenten geprägt
sie wissen ja dass ich anfangs beim kgb
der sowjetunion war und wir wurden dort
entsprechend erzogen zu einer absoluten
treue dem eigenen volk und dem eigenen
staat geben
putins ziele russland zu neuer alter
größe zu führen und der eigenen
machterhalt dazu ist die nahezu jedes
mittel recht medien werden
gleichgeschaltet kritiker verfolgt
eingesperrt und sogar ermordet
der russische oppositionspolitiker
wladimir cara moser hat es am eigenen
leib erlebt er wurde vergiftet zweimal
mutmaßlich mit dem nervengift novy job
er überlebte die anschläge nur knapp man
kann nicht erwarten dass ein regime das
die rechte seines eigenen volkes mit
füßen tritt sich plötzlich auf der
internationalen bühne respektvoll
verhält und internationale regeln
respektieren
das wird nicht passieren
tatsächlich schreck putin von anfang an
nicht vor dem einsatz des militärs
zurück er interveniert in tschetschenien
georgien libyen und syrien
2014 übernehmen soldaten ohne
hoheitszeichen gewaltsam die kontrolle
über die ukrainische halbinsel krim
anfangs erklärt putin russland habe mit
dieser aktion nichts zu tun doch dann
räumt er die wahrheit ein
hinter der selbstverteidigungskräfte
standen natürlich unsere seite die haben
sehr korrekt gehandelt sehr überlegt und
professionell
lügen gehört zum handwerkszeug des kgb
agenten und ist teil der russischen
militärdoktrin
maskierung nennen sie es
ist einfach das russische wort führt
ahnung aber es bedeutet auch täuschen
wir haben gesehen dass die russen keine
neuen negative schaffen können was sie
tun können ist bestehende negative zu
untergraben zweifel zu wecken wo keine
zweifel seien sollten sie versuchen das
gefühl zu vermitteln dass wir nie
wirklich wissen werden was die wahrheit
ist denn das ist die nächst beste
möglichkeit die menschen von einer
alternativen wahrheit zu überzeugen
täuschen tricksen und drohen das ist
putins strategie gegenüber dem ausland
nach innen lässt er hart durchgreifen
proteste gegen den ukraine krieg werden
mit gewalt unterbunden
ich finde es ungeheuerlich dass für
immer noch von westlichen experten hören
dass es irgendwie einen frühen putin und
einen späten putin gab und dass der
frühe putin in ordnung war und dann habe
sich etwas verändert nichts hat sich
geändert wladimir putin war immer
derselbe derselbe mann der in den 1970
er jahren freiwillig zum kgb gegangen
unser interview ist eines der letzten
dass wladimir karama gibt bevor er in
moskau festgenommen wird weil er immer
wieder den krieg angeprangert hat ihm
droht eine jahrelange haftstrafe in
russland wladimir putins